on the bottom for the padres is blake
snell blake snell is uh making his third
start of the second half fourth of his
career versus the a's tossed six innings
last time out one run ball three hit
ball at miami that was in the 3-2
victory his 19th start 241 opponents
batting average here's lowry blake snell
has walked to the asb runners at first
and third
lowry hits one very high in the air to
center
that's profar going back he's still
going back two steps onto the warning
track he grabs it hustles in to score
and the a's grab a one nothing lead on
the long sacrifice fly by jed lowry jed
lowry getting the high breaking ball
straight away center field it's a huge
park at petco park
but mark canna
get into second and then stealing third
gets this a's first run on the ball game
so here's chapman two on two out for the
a's with a run in here in the first
and that one is deep to left field and
that baby is gone
he jumped on what looked like a high
fastball ring and he turned it around
and it's four to nothing the eas lead
and finally the a's get a home run with
runners on base and even more so matt
chapman
good swing on the first pitch from snell
an even better
swing
on the second pitch there's your high
fastball belt high
and it was gone in a heartbeat
i mean it was no law no more swung on
gone there's a lot behind that one i
think even from oakland we could tell
that was going to be a smug odd gun so
sean monae the big left-hander looking
for his eighth win of the year
adam frazier at the top of the order
again he's at second base for the first
time on the padres uniform
ground ball right side it is lowry
throws out frazier for the first down at
the bottom of the first inning manny
machado's lifetime average against he is
is 312. here it is and swung out a
message that changed up away a perfect
pitch and for mania it's a one two three
bottom of the first and after one the
a's lead the padres four nothing now the
one-o to mark
with runners in scoring position
this may work and it will work
alva sanders read it all the way he
comes in to score that's an rbi single
for cana five to nothing the a's lead
ball hit off the end of the bat by mark
canna and elvis anders at second base
base hit himself he's able to score
easily without a throw
snell at 71 pitches on the day
runners at first and third and nobody
out infield looking to turn two ace
leading five nothing the pitch is a curb
bounce on the right side picked up by
chrono with no play at second goes to
first and not in time he delayed and
hustling over his elbows and then to
score as chapman and it's six nothing
oakland
cement experience at first base not eric
hosmer but jay cronenworth
wanted to throw it a second to
potentially start a double play then
hesitated by the time he reacted back to
first with a toss to snell it was too
late at an rbi infield hit for elvis and
good hustle by elvis not taking for
granted that he'd be out and he was
flying down the line so still nobody out
piscotty at second base it's six nothing
oakland
and elvis gets an rbi's 23rd of the year
on a ball that went about 70 feet
six nothing oakland they've scored in
three different innings one out runners
on first and second and those runners
are mania and andrews respectively top
of the order mark cannon
hit well toward left center field
nobody's going to get it
pearl fire back hands gets it back in
but not before elvis anders trots in to
score marcano with his second rbi hit
and it's now seven to nothing you could
also maybe credit
elvis anderson that you talked about
snell
not looking back
but right before he hung that curveball
he looked back
and elvis andrus had taken a couple of
steps then kind of fainted a little bit
back to second base so two runs in at
it's seven nothing oakland here's the
lead off man adam frazier sean manaya
has gone nine up nine down with five
strikeouts his first time through the
padres lineup here comes the o2 breaking
ball swinging the mess he chased one and
he's gone on strikes a half a dozen k's
for mania and 10 in a row retire to
start the game machado on deck next
deliveries sprung on and missed chained
up down and away just finished off tatis
like it was nothing
back to back hayes and seven on the day
for mania the emergence of shamania as a
dominant pitcher in this league has been
a revelation to watch he's pitching
right now like a guy you really want one
out there in a post-season game how
about chamonix he's faced the padres
four innings
twelve batters
she is
on top of it again today tired the first
12 hitters he has faced he'll see fam
cronenworth and myers here in the bottom
of the fifth inning
there's another fastball just came right
at him 92 miles an hour nothing fancy
ray no i
you know when a team gets a hit
sometimes you look at a team are they
going to come back and team that you're
facing and it seems like the padres
little lackluster today with sean and i
making some great pitches he has to
and the 2-2 to myers right down the
middle fastball ring him up nine
strikeouts for mania who has been
perfect through five on this wednesday
in san diego three and one now to
jerickson profile padres have not had a
base runner three and one the delivery
not a profile that's inside there's the
first base runner for the padres and you
can tell manage
really frustrate just trying to throw a
strike
sometimes it's the hardest thing to do
just try to throw one over the middle so
the first san diego base runner
is pro far walking with one out in the
six matt's had a good day two for three
the big three run homer that got things
going for the a's
another change up toward
and the throw is wide and everybody's
safe run comes in to score and it's
ain't nothing so tati's throw was wide
chapman with the good speed
may have forced the issue just a little
bit olson scores one two
reach four little dribbler up the first
baseline and it's gonna stay fair and
they throw it away
and it's down the right side biscotti
picks up the baseball he's gonna hustle
to second base around third is chapman
he's gonna try to score and he will
score
and the a's add on again it's nine
nothing oakland
man all the way from first base on a
ball that went 45 feet up the first
baseline and the a's have scored twice
in the inning
here's the pitch
change up poke toward right field that's
going to land for hit piscotti comes
around third not save away from home and
the a's are into double figures as
piscotti crosses the plate rbi single
for elvis andrews it's 10-00 oakland two
down two on austin nola
neither has uh
wow in the left center coming around
from second is machado
he will score
sennarbia a double for austin nolan the
padres are on the board the bases are
loaded for grisham and remember they've
coined this town slam diego
strike three called anthony's mondelkin
gets the call
padres get one and they leave them
loaded one out ninth inning padres
trailing by nine cudaworth at second
myers at first
line to right piscotty is not going to
get it
it's up against the wall
coming around to score from second is
chronoworth two second with an rbi
double because jericho pro far and it's
10 to two padres not going quietly in
the ninth pitching change with one out
in the ninth inning for the oakland a's
chaffin overall entering his 44th game
ranks fifth among major league relievers
victor carratini to pinch hit 229 six
elmer's 29 runs batted in
keretani with the base hit into right
field myers will score and it's ten to
three pinch hit rbi single for victor
caratini fraser weights
garrosh so far in the center he's still
responsible for pro far at third that
one bounces in gets away here comes
profar he will score
it's time to four
seven pitches missed it back two balls
two strikes ten four is one over third
two out bottom of the ninth
and once again here's the pitch swung
out or missed drops down to
some of the padres make a little noise
in the ninth but nothing to worry about
as the a score early score often and
they get a split in this quick two-game
series and these two teams will see each
other next week at the coliseum